you know the really only thing is I've
got a pink wig somewhere just don't know
where the heck it is so last episode of
the fifth season of Black Mirror man I
wish these were longer but I'll take
what I can get
Rachel Jack and Ashley - this this was
an interesting one now I don't I didn't
dig too much into overall reactions but
just the soft vibe I get was that people
seem to think the least of this one um
for this season of Black Mirror um again
I could be wrong because like that was
just a vague whiff I got so I don't know
if that is the case I can see why
relative to how Black Mirror can be it's
a little bit for lack of a better word
cheesy although for me it was kind of
cheesy in a good way and I also don't
know if there's Miley Cyrus bite back um
she's fine in the part she does pretty
well is actually some parts of it I
think I should it great even but I don't
know I had a lot of fun with this it's
not the best one of the season striking
vipers is the best one of the season by
actually a pretty big margin and well
I'm not gonna go so far as to say that
this is a better like made and executed
product than smithereens was I enjoyed
it more than smithereens I would
personally rank it higher although I
mean depending on what you like out of
your black mirror I think most people
will probably put some other means above
this but I really had a lot of fun with
this so I I what I will admit and what I
will cop to is that the first 20 minutes
half hour ish they were painful for me
because it was dealing with I mean II
was cringy and and like when I use that
word for
of all realize I will never mean it in a
positive light because I hate
entertainment that makes me cringe that
makes me embarrassed for somebody I
don't enjoy that at all now normally
want to bring that up it's in relation
to humor in this case it's not humor but
it's still humiliation and I hate it and
I'm kind of supposed to but like one of
the nature's of cringy things is you see
it coming from a mile away you just have
to watch it unfold and it hurts so when
I say cringy I I pretty much never mean
it as a positive and also it's like I
say it's always painful for me to try
and watch something that I find cringy
that said it was foundational work for
where the story in the characters were
going so I get why it's there it wasn't
gratuitous and because the episode shed
that stuff in order to hit the back end
and do something else I'm prepared to
forgive it that said those first 20 25
minutes were still rough they were hard
for me to watch this young girl to watch
Rachel feel outside of her life to not
feel connected to the school that she's
now and do not feel connected to her
sister to not feel connected to her
father and to take solace in this
bubblegum pop and I don't find that
amusing cuz I don't find that something
that I'd ever mocked somebody for
whatever you find solace in take solace
in it as long as it's not something that
actually hurts anybody take solace in
whatever you need to so I was really
worried that the even if I never
expected the show itself to treat it as
as a point of mockery but to see other
people our characters possibly treat it
that way
I really have my hackles up the the
talent show I am gonna just talk
spoilers in this thing pretty quickly I
think yeah I think more than than the
other ones I'm just gonna roll through
it because most of the nonspells
other stuff is the stuff that I'm kind
of complaining about so you know that
that whole talent show scene that was
painful that I'm like that would like I
had to pause and walk away and then come
back and finish it it hurt it hurt a lot
but it never felt like it was dialing it
up just for the sake of being more
humiliating it was just managing to hold
on to a level of believability with it I
also kind of like the little touch that
the father is like a very blue-collar
guy and he's just he's trying to
literally build a better mousetrap but
like we're at this near future point
where even like a guy who's doing pest
control has this crazy tech setup in his
basement and is messing around with like
the the this artificial brain and this
AI algorithms I kind of find him I found
that surprisingly amusing but let's talk
about Ashley and Ashley - so Ashley -
being the little robot the doll
basically that has been input with the
personality selectively of the performer
Ashley Oh which is Miley Cyrus's
character now first of all I there's a
lot of little subtle things about Ashley
- and it's movements that I really
appreciate I also like the little sort
of cycling in the eyes when it's
processing something that was said to it
it's basically like a buffering I like
that that's a cool little touch I mean
it's totally the sort of thing that that
tech companies were built into somebody
that is like you got a you know if it
has to pause you have to be sure the
user knows it didn't freeze it's
thinking just wait and then it talks
but when yeah
when they when they take the inhibitors
off and it getting proper spoilers now
and it gets revealed that like it wasn't
that partial personality from Ashley
uploaded into this thing it was I mean
it would have been comparing to other
episodes of
like Merritt basically would have been
her cookie getting uploaded into this
thing but then being restricted to only
positive stuff you're very limited
responses so it's not that far off like
from the monkey from black Museum it's a
little bit more sophisticated than that
but it's not too far off of us so when
the limiters get taken office you just
start swearing up a storm it is so
ticked off at everything he's like fine
you can't help me and she's trying to
storm out can somebody open this door
for me it's like oh really I love
actually I mean like Ashlee oh the human
version she was good she was fine
Miley Cyrus played her fairly well I
will actually grant that I'm not sure
that even though Miley Cyrus played the
part fine I'm not sure that it was
actually beneficial to cast her because
given her own status as a pop star it
does come across as a little bit
self-indulgence sort of oh look how hard
it is to be rich and famous and like I
try not to pull that with people because
everybody suffers and like that's the
human condition
everyone is in pain it doesn't matter
what they have and how much
quote-unquote better on paper their life
is than yours they're still in pain so
like I get that but for somehow having a
real-life popstar do that makes it feel
a little bit more self indulgent and
almost like instead of being asked to
sympathize with this character you're
asking us to sympathize with Miley Cyrus
as a person and I I don't think that's
actually what the show was trying to do
but unfortunately that becomes a little
bit of a vibe off of it and again I'm
not saying she's bad in the part I
actually think she's pretty good in the
part I'm just not sure that they should
have gotten a real pop star it's kind of
all I'm saying but but she does she does
pretty well the the ant is delightfully
hateable I've seen her get her
comeuppance was was quite satisfying and
I liked I liked the relationship between
the sisters it's funny I I
don't often connect excessively with
sibling relationships in entertainment
because well probably partly because I'm
an only child so my point of reference
for sibling relationships is limited
it's secondhand it's circumstantial I I
never I didn't have siblings growing up
so that's not my life that's not my
experience but from what I have seen and
having you know been around and known
and seen plenty of siblings and you know
having had those kinds of interactions
in my life it did ring very true for me
the way in which the older sister Jack
you know was very oh you're so dumb why
do you like this music but when she
truly saw that Rachel was in legitimate
pain that she was trying to help
not necessarily by doing what Rachel
would want her to do but you know by
taking actions like this is what'll help
and you know out of genuine concern but
still you know being very frustrated
because like I even though not in a
sibling way I can relate to the family
thing of I love you but I don't like you
right now
so it's uh I thought that was pretty
well captured the dad was like maybe a
little too absent but given what the
sisters were gonna have to be able to
get away with doing as the story
progressed I guess he kind of had to be
but it was a little like I don't know
did did they do face him up just that
touch too much I feel like they did I
don't know
but overall was pretty good like I said
nicely cathartic as well and this
actually boy this makes a series words 2
out of 3 episodes I would say have a
happy ending
hey hey Charlie are you okay like I know
this is weird that like I mean when I
say Charlie I'm talking about Charlie
Brooker the guy who writes Black Mirror
and I'm asking if he's okay when he's
writing more stuff that's like kind of
happy you're right - you sure I'm not
actually complaining because of a lot of
my favorite I mean well my all-time
favorite episode of like mirror is one
of the happy ones and I really liked
striking vipers and I have a lot of fun
with this so while I never really wanted
to become the norm with Black Mirror if
if if he's finding that he wants to end
on a slightly more upbeat note these
days I'm not excited complaining I had
fun with this and if anyone's curious my
ranking for this season because I have
ranked well prior to Bandersnatch coming
out I ranked all the episodes that had
aired up to that point which was 18 at
the time now there's 22 total uh I mean
if people care I guess I could refresh a
ranking of all the episodes I don't know
if I will though we'll see I'm actually
recording this before even the first
episode of my reviewing this season you
know drops so I've no idea what the
responses I like black Mary's done
pretty well for me in the past I just I
just don't know if people will still
come to me for it so we'll see I people
want me to redo that ranking with this
new season and Bandersnatch worked in
how I mean I'll consider it based off
response but for right now let's wrap it
up there Rachel Jack and Ashley - what
did you think about yeah you know what
it was that I felt like in a lot of ways
Ashley - was saying in English the kind
of stuff that I tend to imagine bb-8 and
r2d2 say you know that level of swearing
I just wanted to share that but whatever
your thoughts are drop flip me on the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff to do because it's buttons
least you can help me out on patreon
there's links to merch there's social
media stuff all sorts of things check
them out down below or
I appreciate it but you don't have to
because at the end of the day you are
the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]